I thought okay I'm gonna be fine I'm not
gonna be nervous I'm just gonna say good
vibes and then I got really nervous it
was like my kid brother was the
quarterback at the Super Bowl the video
I think I jumped up on a chair in a
scream I jumped up on a chair and
screamed for about 30 seconds and then
Colin haimes I hugged for about another
40 seconds yeah I'm so proud of them and
it's so well deserved I don't think I
don't think it was a big surprise it's
such an original singular thrilling
story yes I didn't I haven't talked to
him yet I haven't talked about I just
send him okay so now all the people from
Chicago from the second city are sending
texts
at the moment of him winning it slightly
excited me I'm slightly excited for him
so I wish that I had like a simulcast of
his mom in New York she's got to be so
proud I can't sometimes we use bad words
in our text I love mine
but I just I just said hashtag what I
sent her hashtag Oscars so Pele that's
what I'm gonna try to make that catch on
today